[Music]
one of the biggest mistakes we make is
that we confuse
inexperience
with being unqualified one of the most
important questions that i get asked
over and over and over and over again
people are struggling with what do i do
with my life the most successful people
in the world
healthy wealthy or wise choose education
over entertainment
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person i'm not but when you
start your day off with a powerful
routine that inspires you like watch one
of these videos it will change your life
so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee know that i
believe in you and get ready for a shot
of espresso from j shetty
[Music]
of the biggest mistakes we make is that
we confuse
inexperience
with being unqualified
so because we've not tried a lot of
things we just naturally believe that we
can't be that good at them so if i've
never spoken on a stage i just think oh
i'm probably not good at that or if i've
never played golf i'd probably think i'm
probably not good at that and so we
start writing off things without even
trying them so the best method i can
share with someone is take the next
month
take the next four weekends in the month
that gives you eight days
and get really tactical every single day
that's why you're playing tennis a lot
right now yeah
take the eight days
go join a course an online course or
workshop go and shadow a friend go to a
seminar a conference go to reading a
book listen to podcasts go and expose
yourself to eight different things in a
month eight different things eight
different things in a month and guess
what in a month you will have learned
what you probably would have learned in
eight years because most of us test one
new thing a year maybe maybe if that
exactly right like some people don't
even do that but if you do eight
different things in a month and this is
how you have to see it if you went to
eight different restaurants in a month
you ask yourself after you eat a meal
like i had that burrito or i had that
taco did i like it right the first
question you asked yourself is did i try
it first you got to try it first you got
to go to the restaurant yeah there's no
point so you're going to say did i like
it the second question you ask yourself
is why did i or why did i not like it
like why is so important i think too
many people just go i like it or i don't
like it why didn't i like and the third
question you have to ask yourself really
really simple is do i want to do it
again
and if you do
that's where you start uncovering is so
my point is inexperience do not
misinterpret inexperience for a lack of
qualification what do i do with my life
one of the most important questions that
i get asked over and over and over and
over again people are struggling with
what do i do with my life
you see your parents doing something you
see your friends doing something
you know that that's not the life that
you want but you're afraid of actually
chasing down your dreams you see people
living their life on instagram and it's
so beautiful and perfect
and you're worried that you're not gonna
measure up that you're not gonna live up
to it that if you try and do your thing
you're gonna fail
and so you're constantly stuck in this
what do i do with my life pull between
the safe life that everybody around you
is living and they want you to live for
yourself or the dream life that you know
you're capable of but you don't know
quite what it looks like what do i do
with my life
here's what i found you're gonna have
moments in your life where you have
absolute clarity
and equally you'll have moments in your
life where you have zero clue what to do
let's break those two down
when you have absolute clarity when you
know exactly what you want to do when it
feels right when you have momentum the
best thing you can do is put your
blinders on and go to work
the best thing you can do is shut down
everything else and get to work building
your dream
we often hedge we often play small we
often don't put as much in because we're
afraid
but when you have those moments of
clarity you have to go play a bigger
game you have to start betting on
yourself
right now i look at my youtube channels
as an example
this is a pretty special moment in time
and things are very well aligned for me
right now i mean been doing youtube for
12 years built up a lot of traction have
a lot of momentum been helping a lot of
my friends made a lot of new friends as
a result of the channel got into rooms
that otherwise i shouldn't be in because
of the success of my channels
and it's been a lot of work
and the early years did not pay off very
well at all i share on my instagram
a lot of my traction and you know first
five years of the channel
we didn't even have 10 000 subscribers
in the first five years and then we went
and hit you know next five years 2
million subscribers now passing 3
million subscribers on the main channel
but a lot of
a lot of slow slow slow growth
but right now
is a very special moment in time right
now i need to push harder on the youtube
channels right now we've launched i
don't know how many channels a lot of
channels we got a dozen channels plus
maybe at this point i need to be pushing
more on youtube this is a moment in time
this is
the window here is so wide open that i
need to jump through it because at some
point it will close and and i don't want
to look back on this moment and say i
wish i pushed harder i wish i wasn't
afraid i wish i i did the thing that i
knew was right and we'll have it you'll
have those moments too in your life
where you just see it so clearly you you
have this vision you you see it all
working out but you're afraid to go
actually take the action you're afraid
to go all in on it you're afraid to do
what is necessary and then what ends up
happening is regret
because you'll be at the end of your
life or even 10 years later thinking
i knew it i saw it so clearly there was
this opportunity in front of me and i
wanted to do it i love to do it but i
was too afraid and somebody went else
somebody else went off and made millions
of dollars off of my idea does that ever
happen to you somebody made millions off
of my idea
no they just went and took action when
you were sitting being afraid
and so when you have those moments of
clarity you have to push everything else
aside and go after that thing
even though it's scary even though it's
too big even though it feels beyond you
you have to go after that thing because
that's where your genius lies
and you either lean into your genius and
go change the world
or you live the rest of your life with
regret you have to force it
so that's when you have absolute clarity
you'll also have moments in your life
where you have no idea what to do
zero clue like i don't know what to do
next all i know is i don't want to be
doing what i'm doing right now does that
ever happen to you
you know that you don't like your
current life you know that you don't
like your current habits you know that
you don't like your current schedule
your routine what you're doing who
you're hanging with you know you don't
like any of that stuff but you don't
know what to do to change it does that
happen
if that's you right now
then your immediate goal
is the exact opposite it's not to go all
in on one thing it's to try many things
to give yourself a lot of exposure to
say yes to as many things as possible
that are inside your code of ethics
right don't go
steal something from a store because
it's something new
right that are inside your code of
ethics
to taste the test to try to explore to
find the thing that might be the next
thing for you
and to lower the barrier
for just getting started
so i went through this
in my website
when i have my website a lot of people
don't know me from my website because if
you go to my website now there's not
that much there but i used to have a
hundred thousand plus pages of content
on my website and i was playing the seo
game and publishing tons of content and
and we had a lot of the big name people
in entrepreneurship creating content for
our website
and i was selling ads off the site
and i realized at the beginning
i was all in at the beginning i loved it
i wanted to write i wanted to bring on
people i wanted to we had 5 000 people
or so writing for the website i loved it
it was all in i saw this moment in time
i was going for it and we quickly grew
the website but i found that as
maybe year three year four
i was starting to lose interest
wasn't exciting anymore
and i didn't know what else to do inside
the website to
bring that energy back
so i started to taste test explore other
things outside the website and one of
those experiments was youtube
one of those tests was me starting my
first youtube channel
and
i really sucked at it
you can go back and watch my old videos
it took me a long time to get half
decent in front of the camera i sucked
at it
i had no natural inclination for it
i told myself well i'm i'm an introvert
and i'm shy so i'm always gonna suck on
camera
but i realized i don't know i just i
liked it
i liked it i liked doing it i liked
making visual content instead of written
content because i'm a visual learner i
like the idea that
maybe there's somebody else out there
who watch my video and be inspired by it
and that maybe makes a shift for them i
never expected to be youtube famous
because at the time youtube famous
wasn't a thing nobody was youtube famous
especially in education
nobody was making long-form educational
videos it just didn't exist
and so i thought you know what i'll just
keep doing it because i love it that if
50 people 100 people watch this video
that's 1500 people who watch the video
that's maybe a couple lives change
because of me
being courageous enough at the time to
press record and make a video
and so that kept me that kept me going
and eventually i turned it into
something that then i shut down my
website and it went all in on youtube
and so
when you don't know what to do
[Music]
you need to get out of your typical
routine go for a walk go to go go drive
somewhere you've never been before take
an extra long shower like do the things
that help get you create creative ideas
and then whatever comes
whether it's start a youtube channel
start a podcast start writing a book
start singing a song start like whatever
ideas come to you they will probably
sound crazy
for someone like me it would be crazy to
have a youtube channel
for someone who doesn't like being in
front of the camera
who doesn't like seeing himself who who
thought that people who
filmed themselves had to have a huge ego
and be chasing fame and i didn't want
that
for someone like that
i would have never said never never that
i would have a hundred thousand
subscribers you know let alone three
million plus never i would have never
thought that was possible
and so a lot of times these new ideas
that we come up with seem impossible
feel impossible for someone like you to
do something like that there's no way
that that's going to happen
and so we've already lost out of the
gate because you don't give yourself
permission to try you set these
impossible benchmarks and milestones
for yourself and the lack of belief in
yourself means that you don't even do it
so reduce that barrier bring it down to
nothing just start just experiment just
create your first video record your
first podcast sing your first song write
your first page of a book right try that
one thing
and the only thing that matters is did
you like the thing
do you want to go back and do it again
was it enjoyable whether you got a
result or not you probably won't get a
good result your first thing will suck
expect it to suck but did you like the
thing
do you want to go back and do it again
was it actually fun as opposed to being
a chore
because the more that you keep doing the
things that you actually find fun doing
you can guess what you're going to get
better at it
you're going to get better at it right
like if you actually like learning the
thing you're gonna get better at it
think about all the stuff you learned in
school that you never actually learned
you just memorized and it's gone versus
the things that you actually enjoy doing
that's the stuff that actually sticks so
you can get great at any skill if you
actually love doing it and it doesn't
feel like work and so that becomes the
immediate job is to figure out what is
the thing that you potentially will love
doing and to say yes to
you say yes to every idea that comes
into your head stop judging the results
of them give yourself permission to
start small to fail small and just pay
attention to do you love that thing can
you wait to go back and do it again
so
this happens for
everybody
this will happen multiple times in your
life
there will be moments where you have
absolute clarity absolute certainty you
know what you need to do next you feel
it in your bones
you have to go do it and you have to
play bigger you have to stop being
afraid you have to go all in on that
thing because that window will close and
you will regret not going bigger when
you had the chance
and then when you have those moments
where you have no idea what to do
you're of zero clue you feel completely
lost
that's when you have to explore
get out of your comfort zone get out
your usual routine go for a walk listen
to that creative inspiration that does
come stop judging those ideas and just
starting them and giving yourself the
permission to fail
because you will find the next big thing
and this is roller coaster
effect that will happen many times in
your life of absolute clarity and zero
clarity and maybe those cycles last
weeks months years
for youtube has been over a decade and
i'm still going strong on it but at some
point that's going to shift to something
else and that's okay and that's normal
so recognize where you are at within
your life right now where are you right
right now do you have absolute
confidence and clarity or do you have
zero confidence and clarity
and then take the right step forward now
i've got some special bonus clips that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you just watch a video and get
motivated you have a 35 chance of
actually doing something making a change
that's what the sign says 35 percent
that's not on that believe nation but
when you watch a video you get motivated
and then you create a specific plan of
action for what you're going to do
it jumps to 91 chance of you following
through and when you commit publicly
like putting it in the comments below
what your plan is it jumps to 95
so believe nation your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below so i can celebrate
with you hey everyone i have been
reading a bit from my friend's book evan
carmichael built to serve and i wanted
to share this with you so
according to a study by carnegie mellon
university people with supportive
spouses are more likely to give
themselves the chance to succeed they
studied 163 married couples and found
that people with supportive spouses were
more likely to take on potentially
rewarding challenges those who accepted
challenges experience more personal
growth happiness and psychological
well-being now i can truly say that i've
experienced that in my life when i first
met my wife i was just starting out i
had never released a video i hadn't
created any content and she was such an
important part of feeling supported on
that journey so whether you're in a
relationship whether you're dating
whether you're married or even if you're
single being supported by friends and a
strong community is important uh built
to serve by ellen carmichael great book
on how you can find your purpose and
also on reminding us that we can all
make a difference in the world thanks
evan a young boy once asked his teacher
what's the difference between i like you
and i love you the teacher beautifully
answered well it's like a flower if you
like a flower
you pluck it but if you love a flower
you water it and nurture it daily
and watch it grow there is such a thin
line between light and love and because
of it we make so many mistakes in our
relationships when we want something in
the moment we take it
and don't think any further we do
whatever we want to get that feeling of
pleasure
not realizing that we're neither
satisfied by that pleasure
and nor will that thing last when we
pluck a flower
not only will that flower die
but we can't experience it for any
longer than that moment
when you water it and take care of it
daily
you can experience it forever we've been
wired towards an instant gratification
instant pleasure mindset all of the
adverts that we see whether they're
online or offline are geared to driving
us towards making instant decisions for
instant promises of pleasure the catch
is
not only does that instant pleasure not
satisfy us
the feeling doesn't last we're so used
to seeing all the strap lines and
headlines on the internet learn this
language in five minutes get the ideal
body in 10 minutes a day become a
millionaire in 12 months now all of
these sound brilliant right
the problem is they're not real they're
not true
they're false promises the reason why it
works is because it appeals to one of
the most basic human desires
situational improvement without major
resource investment
of course you can pick up a few words in
another language or shed a few pounds of
weight if that was your goal or maybe
you will make a little bit more money
but real knowledge
real
awareness real fitness real business
all of these things take time
real relationships real connection
real purpose
takes time naturally the internet
headlines focus on the short term
instead of the long term because most of
us would never click on something if it
said learn the language in five years
with dedicated daily practice we
wouldn't click on something that said
here is the one hour workout that you
need to do every single day and we
wouldn't click on the one that said if
you want to be a millionaire here are
the ten failures that you will go
through in year one how broke you might
be by year three and you may not even
make it by year nine the important
lesson here is if you want meaning if
you want purpose if you want fulfillment
those things take time you talked about
the fear of fear and how you had to
learn to let go of your fear of fear
what does actually mean letting go of
the fear of fear yeah so i talk about
how we fear the wrong things
what do we fear so most of us are
fearful of how our friends are reacting
what's happening on social media and
what's the random bit of news that we
heard
none of it is fact based that's one of
the biggest issues worry-based it's
worry-based and it's also imagination
based so we become fiction writers we've
all watched too many movies now we start
writing these beautiful movies in our
head we're not beautiful scary movies in
our head of what may happen so our
imagination and seneca said it best we
suffer twice one in reality and one in
imagination right we suffer twice and
this is the way what actually happens to
us
in the story we continue to tell you
totally now there's this incredible
study in the book that i have to talk
about so they took monks and they took
non-monks and they
competed against each other
so they put this plate where you
experience heat
and so what happens is the non-monks
touch this plate now this plate heats up
gradually
softly and then at one point it gets
really hot for 10 seconds then it cools
down and so what happened is that when
the non-monks touched it the anxiety and
pressure and stress in their brain just
triggered straight away even though it
wasn't that hot it wasn't hard it was
heating but it wasn't hard to do
anything major to you but the anxiety
and stress in imagination or in
anticipation went through the roof in
the non-monks now this is what's
fascinating when the monks touched it
they showed that it didn't feel anything
as it rose but as it got to its highest
they felt physical pain but they showed
no trigger of emotional pain because
they did not assign any emotional
element to that pain so my point with
that is
you can look at the news right now
and you can get scared straight away
and get incomplete freeze mode feeling
stuck paralyzed whatever it is because
what you're now doing is you're creating
a story of what's going to happen
and that story and you can cause
sickness in yourself you can question
just by the story not actually the
reality the the facts of the disease
hitting you or
something happening physically to you
totally and that story again can be used
positively so your story may actually be
true
but if it's going to be true now you can
prepare and that shifts you away from
being scared because now you're
preparing and so the real you can be
confident because you're prepared
exactly and so we should be shifting our
fear energy
into preparation energy because what
fear does is it keeps you locked there
right we just feel stuck
i'll give you an example when you were
preparing for big games when you used to
play in the nfl right and you're playing
american football against some of the
biggest athletes in the world
it's like you can either sit there and
be scared that you're going to play this
game on the weekend or you can prepare
and your confidence is in the
preparation so when people go how do i
feel confident right now
are you preparing are you putting the
reps are you putting the rats are you
building your immunity are you taking
your vitamins are you drinking lots of
water are you drinking lots of water are
you taking the steps that are needed to
prepare for whatever's coming you will
feel more confident that way yeah one of
my biggest beliefs
and i read a study that inspired my
beginning and it was that the most
successful people in the world healthy
wealthy or wise choose education over
entertainment
and the most unsuccessful people in the
world unhealthy unwealthy or unwise
choose entertainment over education
so i made it my mission in life
to build entertainment first content
with an educational heart
and i was thinking how do we make wisdom
spread at the pace people want
entertainment
how do we meet people where they are so
that they can come on a journey with us
how do we meet people because guess what
hundreds of thousands of people will do
courses millions of people will come to
events but billions will always watch
television
and network tv and online programming
how do we meet people there
so a big part of my vision and goal is
to create conscious content
that will sit on all the platforms that
everyone binge watches will be extremely
entertaining that you won't even know
but it will have the most meaningful
messages behind it at 18 i was really
fortunate when i met a monk and this
monk was invited to speak and i kind of
just went because one of my friends
forced me to at that time i was
listening to ceos and entrepreneurs and
business people and marketers who who i
thought that's what i was aspiring to be
like and then i hear this monk
and he captivated me like no one had
ever captivated me before
it was like staring at the most
beautiful woman on the planet you know i
was completely fixated on him and his
message see we live in echo chambers
we're just surrounded by the same
thinking how often do you bump into a
monk you know it just doesn't happen you
don't have no one has a dinner party and
goes oh yeah we just invited the monk
you know from town like the local monk
like no one ever does that and so you we
meet people who are just like us most of
the time
and we talk about this in business all
the time if you want to be a billionaire
spend time with billionaires if you want
to be a millionaire spend time with
millionaires if you want to be a tech
startup spend time with you know that's
that's the common rhetoric that we hear
all the time
but what if you want to find purpose and
master the mind there's no one better
than a monk who's mastered the mind
so so for me the first step is just
opening yourself up to new experiences
and new role models
because most of us can't see ourselves
in people so then we try and fit
ourselves into the boxes that we do see
and and i mean there's this beautiful
quote that i've been saying it
everywhere and i wish i wrote it but i
didn't so it's by a philosopher and
writer named cooley
and he said that today i'm not what i
think i am i'm not what you think i am
i am what i think you think i am
right and just let that blow your mind
for a moment it's uh it's so powerful
i'm not what i think i am i'm not what
you think i am
i am what i think you think i am
so we live in this perception of a
perception of ourselves
hence my identity is made by what my
parents think i should be my identity is
made up by what my college or university
thinks i should achieve
while you're living in that bubble in
that echo chamber getting to what you
really want to do is impossible because
maybe that just doesn't fit and i think
so many people feel that way today
that they don't fit into the current
education system they don't fit with the
three or four or five careers that
you're taught exist
so
that process of self-excavation and
actualization
first requires being exposed you can't
be what you can't see if i never saw a
monk i would never have wanted to be a
monk if i never meet a billionaire i
wouldn't want to be one because i
wouldn't know what that feels like i
don't know what it looks like i don't
know what it takes
and and i think that's the biggest
challenge of our society that we're not
exposed so that's the first step being
exposed to unique experiences and role
models
second step is finding that experience
or role model that you're passionate
about and exactly like you said taking
it seriously shadow their network with
them spend time with them observe them
even from afar it takes that observation
being addicted to observing that
person's lifestyle
and then the third step is going yes or
no
does that work for me
not everyone who's going to go off and
become a monk is going to feel like the
way i did and that's cool
but not everyone is going to go and
follow and shadow a billionaire and go
that's exactly the lifestyle i want they
may want the result but do they want the
hard work that goes with it and so for
me that's the third step it's observing
focusing shadowing getting as close to
the process of that individual and then
going yes or no do i want that process
not do i want the result everyone wants
to be that monk who's fully enlightened
you know can walk through has an
incredible aura that people just
gravitate towards but when you realize
he has to wake up at 2 a.m every day and
sleeps about four to six hours you're
like ah you know i don't want to do it
that doesn't sound like me how many of
you spend a lot of your days
multitasking
okay good so a lot of us spend our time
multitasking now studies show that
only two percent of us
are actually able to multitask
and when most people hear that they're
like yeah i'm in that two percent
that's me right i'm in that two percent
uh you're probably not i'm not because
it's only two percent of the global
population of the world multitasking's a
myth
and i find that as spiritual activists
as conscious change makers as change
agents of the world whatever you want to
call yourself
all of us one of the biggest mistakes
we've seen and this was the quote that i
shared and a thought from martin luther
king that i've really held close to me
is he said those who love peace
need to learn to organize themselves as
well as those who love war
right those who love peace need to learn
to organize themselves as well as those
who love war i.e people are trying to
build
destruction in the world and
distractions in the world are highly
organized highly focused
highly data oriented highly strategic
highly process driven
and so we have to be the same and when
you spend time with vision you spend
time with the mind valley team you
realize their success is intuitive it is
deep it is full of love but it is also
highly strategic it is also highly
focused and therefore it's effective
and so for me
my plea to all of you and to myself is
whatever we're going to do let's get
really strategic about it
let's bring sincerity and strategy
together
let's bring data and dynamism together
let's bring intuition and insight
together
right let's not let's not look beyond
that and think oh that stuff's going to
work out because i intend my intention's
nice
right your intention is not going to run
a mile
but it will help you run the marathon
but it's not going to run that mile that
you need to do right now and so for me
intention and action intention and
attention both of them are required and
so my recommendation is whatever your
dream is whatever you're inspired by
whatever you think is going to have a
positive impact on the world bring both
to that right don't settle for one or
the other we're wired for generosity but
we're educated for greed i think i just
said it to you two years ago when i was
on the podcast it's like and when i said
that and the statement it was
so true we're wired for generosity but
we're educated for greed because what
happens is when we're kids
you'll see kids you want to share go out
their way they want to share my candy
bar whatever
yeah and then as we get older we're told
that there's less and this is what the
key is as we get older we're told there
are finite numbers
of how many kids get made on the
basketball baseball team we're told
there's a finite number of college
spaces we're told there's a finite
number of how many tickets there are
we're told there's a finite number of
people that are successful guess what
in the theater of happiness there are
infinite and unlimited seats and there
is a seat with your name on it
there is a seat with your name on it in
the theater of dreams in the theater of
happiness but you think that because you
think that there are only 100 people
allowed in that if someone else makes it
before you that you don't get in and
guess what is there a cap on how many
billionaires there are in the world no
no is there a cap on how many
millionaires around the world no is
there a cap on how many happy people
there are in the world no and that's why
i really am encouraging forms i want
forbes forget printing a rich list print
the happy list pick a service list bring
a list of who is we should do that we
should do that serving the most in the
world wow
it'll be competition yeah yeah sure i
gave more than you get and that's why it
should be serviced based on time energy
and money because we should start
showing how much time people give how
much energy people give mother teresa i
don't think she gave any money to her
charities right but you get a lot of
time and energy yeah you know you look
at all the people who made a change in
the world martin luther king gandhi like
they may not have given a lot of money
to stuff yeah they gave time and energy
you don't have to give resources but
your resourcefulness your love your
loved one your focus your attention your
compassion love that uh you know the
resourcefulness of the of the heart not
of the wallet
i think you love that and you don't need
to have a lot of money to make a big
impact you don't there's and and this is
the training see we've been educated for
greed because we've been told
everything's limited
there's limited number of this limited
number of this number and every time
you're playing numbers and i think it
was bob marley who said it but every
time you play in numbers you'll always
be dissatisfied because guess what
someone's always have more someone's
always gonna have more i was speaking to
a friend recently
and it's me and and this friend was
telling me that
he
uh you know bought a home which is very
expensive very very expensive and he
went to a party at someone else's house
and he told me that when he was getting
a tour of this party he found out that
this person had a painting on his wall
which cost the amount his house caught
and so he was joking he was like that
that guy's painting in the house he's
got my house on his wall wow and and
that just puts things into perspective
and you think about that like and then
you look at something like jeff bezos
and you think oh well he's the richest
man in the world but does he have the
most fame
no he doesn't
does he have the most beauty
subjective decision does he have the
most strength or power maybe not and so
no one has the most of everything so
when you measure yourself by numbers
you'll always be second third fourth
fifth in something i do feel that it's
my responsibility
to get my intentions right and so one of
my biggest visualizations that i do do
in the morning
is i
so i believe that good intentions in our
life are seeds and bad intentions are
weeds and so what is seeds and wheat
systems
every single day he's getting the
followers he's going to get the likes
with the seeds and weeds
every
that's very snoop it's very snoop
yeah yeah different different seeds and
different ways
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely yeah i i
like that yeah thanks mate
no so i was saying so what i do is i
reflect on my intentions visually every
day
and i think about how many deals am i
taking just because they make me money
or how many videos am i making just
because they get me views or how much
stuff am i doing just for the vanity or
just for the fame or success or what i
think is is going to be good for me like
financially economic like how the how
the default mind is set up to think
about security as opposed to love and
compassion and wanting to change the
world and wanting to make a different
place and i'm constantly battling with
the two so what i'll do every day is
i'll reflect on my intentions i'll
reflect on the deals i've just signed
i'll reflect on
things i'm being offered and i'll
literally
look at each offer deal whatever it is
each item of thought and i'll say is
that a seed or a weed
and if it's a weed i'll pluck it out
i'll literally visualize myself plucking
out of the the garden of my mind and
pulling it out and taking it out and if
it's a seed then i'll water it and i'll
say okay i want that to grow because i
am doing that for the right intention
when you can be trusted with the small
things and the small moments you get
trusted more and more and more and so
like it helps to just
in that moment and it's in those painful
moments that you realize how powerful
you are we all know that like you really
recognize it and and what you said was
beautiful about not rushing through the
pain because and and you know this
example's probably been shared before
but if you have a wound and you've cut
yourself it's like
you can't rush
the healing
you can't rush it if you broke your arm
i mean and you've been through so many
bodily injuries you can't rush the
process it's gonna take six weeks
minimum to heal broken bone yeah
and you've got to sit through that it's
huge there's no injections you can take
there's no videos you can watch there's
nothing you can listen to but our
challenge is we try and rush through the
pain
rather than reflect through the pain we
try to rush the healing process try to
rush the healing and you can't rush
healing and healing is meant to be slow
because it buys you time it buys you
reflection it gives you so much space to
slow down to slow down and that's what
your body is calling out from this is
our emergency like how many times have
you heard it when you slow down
you slow down and that's when you fall
ill
because guess what your body has been
trying to tell you to slow down when you
feel pain so i write about it and think
like
pain makes you pay attention yeah that's
what pain is for
pains notice this notice this notice me
look at me it's crazy it's like a crying
baby craving for attention when a baby's
crying you don't just go eyes crying you
just go oh yeah we'll just put it in
another room and forget about it right
like you go to and you find its needs
whereas without pain when something's
painful we're just like oh yeah i'll
just forget about it i'll escape from it
i'll do something else you have to go
into that i'm not the person
the pain that's saying or whatever yeah
a 100 that's that's usually our response
is what can i do to numb this work more
have sex more drink more whatever's more
whatever it is rather than let me
actually become alert and guess what the
pain just gets higher and higher and
higher and higher because unfortunately
until it really hurts we don't stop or
you need more and more to numb it with
so true now it's incredible that we root
for underdogs
it's incredible that we want underdogs
to win why because we're used to wanting
our team to win we're used to wanting
the best to win we're used to wanting to
associate ourselves with people who are
successful right we never go oh yeah i
know someone who plays for that really
bad team like we don't say that right we
say things like oh i know someone who
plays for that really good team i know
someone who was mvp i know someone who's
the son or the daughter of the mvp we
try and associate or link ourselves to
success
and when we do that
it in turn makes us feel more successful
it's one of the reasons why when your
team wins you say we won right you say
we won but when someone asks you oh how
did your team do and if they lost that
day you say they lost you rarely say we
lost it's incredible how psychologically
we distance ourselves from failure
and we closen or liken ourselves to
success but the exception to that rule
is the underdog we all get excited by
underdogs we all get motivated by
underdogs we feel
completely enamored by the story of the
underdog prashan underdogs are just
simple-minded they don't have
expectations and don't have anything to
prove to anybody and prashant you've
just hit the nail on the head
that's the principle i'm trying to get
across
actually we should play like champions
and train like underdogs why because the
underdog works in a way not worrying
about what anybody else thinks or
believes
that gives you
an edge it gives you a phenomenal
advantage when you're actually worried
about what will people say when you're
not concerned by am i going to fail am i
going to look worse is what i'm doing
not going to succeed as an underdog you
don't let those things cloud your mind
you can focus in on the task at hand see
when we become successful even as
underdogs if we've risen to success
the biggest
enemy of that success the biggest
achilles heel the biggest thing that can
trip us up
is not reconnecting to that feeling of
an underdog so no matter how much
success you've achieved no matter where
you are always remind yourself the
mindset of an underdog is the mindset
that nurtures talent that nurtures
success that harnesses your true
potential what's the impact that you
want to have on the world
i think you've you've
said it so beautifully so many times and
shared my vision which is wonderful and
it's wonderful to know that we share the
same thing it's making wisdom go viral
there's an incredible study in 2017 that
said the most
successful people in the world
healthy
wealthy and wise
choose education over entertainment
the impact i want to have from the world
is i want to transform and revolutionize
the entertainment industry
so that it becomes educational without
anyone knowing
so it's still completely entertaining
it's still like watching netflix but
you're learning about human behavior the
mind neuroscience and everything without
even knowing you are to me that's the
greatest win that we can have for our
society
how many people are gonna quit watching
netflix and reading a book every night i
don't know
but if we can make that book come to
life on netflix that's gonna change the
world because that's what people are
going to consume so for so long media
has been used to numb people to to
switch people off if we can use it to
excite elevate and enlighten people
not by just
not by like the cheesy way of like oh
let's follow someone through their
journey of enlightenment it's not like
that kind of stuff i mean like really
entertaining programming
where you can
learn by being entertained at the same
time if i can do that by changing the
most powerful industry in the world then
i will feel that i've had some some
whatever an impact
because that way i think we'll reach the
world without having to get everyone to
change their habits too much
my thing is how do we meet people where
they are and and really deliver a
message and a powerful
expression of love and to me that's the
highest form of compassion the highest
form of empathy love and compassion
is to meet people where they already are
rather than expecting them to change
[Music]
let me tell you about this girl called
cleo
i think you might know someone like her
too she had the dream of becoming a
model she said she was going to move to
la to pursue it seriously she took care
of herself
at least her body well someone told me
she did ads for l'oreal she had so many
followers on instagram who all loved her
within a minute of her posting a picture
there would be hundreds and hundreds of
comments all telling her how beautiful
she was how good she looked
comment after comment like after like
she was a real entertainer she was
always making everyone laugh
i remember every guy wanted her number
but she kept to herself she just had
this infectious energy she got along
with everyone she was always the life of
the party she was never seen in the same
outfit twice boxes and boxes of amazon
prime on instagram she was the perfect
girl with the perfect life the perfect
world with the perfect guys but
nothing's perfect right it seemed like
she was always having the best time with
her friends always traveling new
experiences and so many great stories to
share until people started to notice
i think she lived like two lives no one
really knew her inside she had everyone
to text but no one to talk to
everyone to follow
but no one to walk with when the phone
was up her world was a stage when it was
down a reality came she had an invite to
every event but still felt lonely
she had all the friends in the world but
still felt no one really knows me she
was going through pain but never showed
that side it was something she hid from
the world
or maybe we just never asked
she had masked her sadness with what
looked like the ideal life
she was always flying high in the air
but felt low inside
her inbox was always full
but she felt empty within
she was happy on the outside
but struggling with depression and
anxiety
she had an addiction that everyone
called a lifestyle
but she was struggling with mental
health
but people were just occupied by her
physical appearance
see people think depression is sadness
people think depression is crying
people think depression is being quiet
depression is when we smile
but we want to cry
it's when we talk but we want to be
quiet
it's when we pretend like we're happy
but we're not depression is not always
obvious
she drank to drown her pain but the pain
learned how to swim
she was sick of crying tired of trying
smiling
but inside she was dying
it's amazing how we can think we know
someone and still not know them at all
i don't think we understand how
stressful it is to explain what's going
on in your head when you don't even
understand yourself we use filters to
lighten our photos whilst we carry the
heavy weight of stress remember it's
okay to have highlight reels but make
sure someone knows how you really feel
it's okay to use face time but make sure
you spend quality time face to face
it's okay to have followers but make
sure you have true friends
don't live for the approval of others
document the moments you're most in love
with yourself
not just the moments you think people
will love the most when someone doesn't
post for a few days
we ask if they're okay
when someone posts every day we assume
they are tell people you love them
be a trustworthy friend
tell them that they matter
tell them that they've survived a lot
and they're ready to thrive now people
who care will ask how you're doing
people who love you
will wait till you tell the truth and
that's why robin williams said
i used to think that the worst thing in
life was to end up alone
it's not
the worst thing in life is to end up
with people who make you feel alone
something that happens is you have to
surround yourself by
peers in a space too who understand you
and don't see you as competition
and that's really hard and it's like a
fine line i genuinely believe that
collaboration wins always
so i my whole approach to most things
has always been hey i want to
collaborate with you whether i'm bigger
on social media or smaller on social
media i'm just like i just want to work
together because i think that's going to
win long term for all of us both not
just in terms of success in numbers but
more in terms of i want to be friends
with you
and so i reach out regularly to people
that i admire in different ways
and i reach out to them and say hey i'd
love to get to know you i'd love to
learn from you i'd love to connect i'd
love to be a friend like not i'd love to
for you to teach me how you do this
and if that comes naturally from that
relationship amazing if it never evolves
into that i've just got a great friend
who now gets me so i try and make
friends in two areas one is in an area
of people who understand my life because
i feel the conversations you can have
with someone who does exactly what you
do
are just so great because they already
get you right and uh someone that i had
on my podcast lately her name is lily
singh superwoman uh she's become a
recent friend she's been incredibly and
is incredibly successful on social media
she's using her platform for doing
amazing good in the world
and she was someone i reached out to
because i was just like hey like you've
been doing all of this for a while you
started on youtube a lot longer than i
did and i would just love to connect
from you and hear from you and she's
become an incredible friend
and we've just been sharing ideas and
learning together and it's like that
relationship's awesome and then at the
same time i'm trying to find people who
are not in media so i still have
friendships with the monks back in india
and i just spent january in india for a
month i was meditating again for
roughly about 21 days
and i have them in my life because they
remind me of like the roots and they
remind me of the truths that bring me
back
so i kind of like both i love people who
totally get my space
and usually those are people i reach out
to
and then i love having my roots down so
most of my inner circle now is from
people i've reached out to
or they've become people who've been
reaching out to me for a long long time
and have been consistently reaching out
to me asking for nothing the challenge
is that we think
things
come with emotions
feelings we think things come with
feelings and emotions and guess what
they don't so if you chase money well
they might for a moment right or they
won't i don't think they even do also
it's such a false sense of feeling i
don't maybe for a moment but it's so
short-lived that it's it's not even
worth counting almost so it's like when
you
when you think that i'm chasing money
guess what you will get money yep and
that's great money is really important
and money is a really important resource
but guess what money is not now going to
fill that gap that void that feeling
that emotion that you're missing in your
life what are most people missing
we're missing a deep sense of love i
think i think the biggest need in the
world as we've heard many times before
from all the ancient texts they they
summarize it like this to love and be
loved like that is the need of humanity
to love and be loved and when we don't
experience that we then start looking
for status we then start looking for
money then we then start looking for
recognition just to help us give the
feeling a false sense of love correct
and the challenge is because most of us
didn't experience that from our parents
and this is the key thing
what we crave in life
is what we did or didn't get from our
parents what our parents did give us is
what we continue to crave or what they
didn't give us is what we continue to
crave so you'll find that most people's
love languages that they chase
are things that their parents didn't
give them so if their parents didn't
give them time they now crave everyone's
time if their parents didn't give them
gifts they'd crave gifts if their
parents didn't give them acts of service
they're craving those acts of service so
it's because of our childhood
and if we don't learn
to process all of that experience which
most people never get the time to do and
i empathize with that because i've had
to go through that i've seen me
repeating my parents patterns
what was the thing you were craving so i
would crave a big thing for me was i
would crave surprises and gifts because
that's your thing yeah that's my thing
still is your thing they still might be
yeah and and i did your parents not do
that for you no they did it my mom did a
lot of it that's why you're still crazy
correct so my mom would always every
year on my birthday
she'd always surprise me with the one
thing i wanted and i wasn't spoiled
growing up i didn't have a lot growing
up but she would get that one thing
whether it was like a power rangers toy
or whether it was whatever it was you
know something
yeah things you want as a kid right and
she would always surprise me with that
and that became so deep rooted now i'll
give you an example when i then married
my wife
you just expect people to know that that
they're going to do the same thing
totally actually
no because i'm expecting my wife to be
like my mom in the sense of i expected a
surprise or show me love in the same way
and she doesn't know that she's not a
mind reader i can't explain expect her
to know that so it took communication it
took time for me to explain that so
anyway i think that's where it stems
from that desire
it doesn't come from any you can say it
comes from society and education of
course it does but i think the deepest
place it comes is what your parents did
or didn't give you that's that's where
it comes from yeah in the middle of 2009
he was the software engineer that no one
wanted to hire he had 12 years of
experience at yahoo but he was rejected
by facebook and then rejected by twitter
he'd been to a great university he had a
great cv
but he decided to team up with one of
his alumni members at yahoo and started
to create an app and focus on the
startup space in five years time he sold
that app for 19 billion dollars to
facebook believe it or not that was
brian acton the co-founder of whatsapp
when he was rejected from facebook he
said it was a great opportunity to
connect with some fantastic people i
look forward to life's next adventure
when he was rejected by twitter he
responded by saying
worked out it was quite a long commute
it's so interesting to see that someone
rejected from two of the top internet
companies actually responded with humor
and actually responded with positivity
this lady was diagnosed with clinical
depression her marriage had failed and
she was jobless with a dependent child
she was on a four hour delayed train
journey from manchester to london when
she came up with this idea and she
started to write this book about this
wizard and as she started writing she
then finished her manuscript took it to
12 publishers and was rejected by all 12
believe it or not that's jk rowling this
man watched his first company crumble he
was a harvard university dropout and his
first company's demo didn't even work he
went on to build microsoft his name's
bill gates therefore failure is just a
sign that we need to widen our scope we
need to be ready and build ourselves up
for the next level actually what we end
up achieving is far greater than what
we'd envisioned for ourselves and this
divine plan this orchestration can't be
happening without this intervention that
occurs because if we had it our way we'd
just settle we just accept what we
thought was our goal what we thought we
were chasing but actually i've noticed
that when you don't get that later down
the line you look back and you reflect
and realize that what you've gained is
so much greater failures are only
failures when we don't learn from them
because when we learn from them they
become lessons and we actually
extrapolate all of these teachings and
actually get more insight into how we
can improve the way we work and how we
can actually drive with a different
energy the challenge we have is that we
only talk about people's failures when
they succeed and that's why they become
this taboo or we feel like their
failures never happen we need to share
these stories earlier we need to bring
out these stories and experiences on the
journey so that people who are on the
journey can actually follow in those
footsteps and that's why steve jobs said
you can't connect the dots moving
forward you only can when you're looking
backwards fred smith was an
undergraduate at yale university in 1965
as part of his coursework he wrote an
economics paper exploring the
transportation of goods in the united
states it's how things get delivered to
you and me he found that shippers were
transporting large packages and items
either via truck or through passenger
airplanes he thought he had a more
efficient method he wrote a last-minute
paper as you do about how a company
transporting small items via a plane
would be a much better business model
because he was rushed he never really
got around to explaining in the paper
how that company would run and he ended
up getting a c the funny thing is he
still didn't give up and in 1971 he
actually launched the company he was
speaking about but within three years of
founding the company federal express as
it was called was actually on the verge
of bankruptcy they were losing over a
million a month that was because of
rising fuel costs competitors in the
same market and at its zenith it was
only worth about five thousand dollars
smith even made a final pitch to general
dynamics hoping for more funding and it
was rejected most people at this point
probably would have just shut down
rejection the grade c losing a million a
month but fred smith had different ideas
smith actually ended up flying to las
vegas that weekend with all of what the
company had the five thousand dollars
the monday morning after the company had
thirty two thousand dollars thanks to
his blackjack skills that money made it
possible to cover fuel costs for just a
few days more soon after the company was
able to raise significant funds he went
around to multiple places to find
sponsors investors people that believed
in what he was trying to achieve as a
service the amazing thing is that he was
creating a company that we all know
today it's called fedex it now operates
in over 220 countries and has an annual
revenue of over 45 billion dollars the
interesting lesson that we can learn
here is that there were countless
occasions in fred smith's life where he
could have said that's it it's not
working for me he could have stopped
when he got that c for the paper he
could have stopped when he was losing a
million a month he could have even
stopped when he finally only had enough
to just last a few more days but he
believed in his vision he had belief he
had conviction about his idea and the
process and the service that he was
creating and that's the lesson here if
you really want to achieve something
you'll find a way and if you don't
you'll find excuses there are sometimes
when i'm
with a social media person who says
something really useful for my roots and
there's someone comes around with roots
and they say something else and there's
a great story actually about when the
prime minister of india modi he visited
facebook and mark zuckerberg interviewed
him at facebook at the headquarters and
mark zuckerberg told his story he said
that when he was struggling with the
direction of facebook in 2009
he went up to his mentor to ask a
question now smart zuckerberg's mentor
happened to be steve jobs and so he went
up to steve jobs and he said steve i'm
struggling with the direction of
facebook what do i do
and at that time you know i mean steve
jobs is steve jobs he could have said
anything and it would have made sense
but
you know he could have said go and meet
a venture capitalist he could have said
go and be an investor he could have said
go and meet a tech company he could have
said i'll tell you what to do. instead
he said i think you need to go to india
and spend some time in an ashram a
monastery in india with monks he goes
when you do that you'll find the answer
of what you want to do
and to me that is exactly why the people
that are most successful in this world
are successful because they surround
themselves
with people who have differing beliefs
and mit did a reset study on this they
found that people who are more
innovative and creative in an
organization
knew people who didn't know each other
so when you know people who all know
each other you end up with the same
answer the same belief and confirmation
bias exists and you just keep building
that echo chamber whereas if you've got
two people who don't agree and you get a
checking system
then you can trust your gut and go with
what you believe so i think i try and
move away from having people around me
and it's not just yes men or yes women
it's about
it's not just about that it's about
building a circle of people like you
said
that want different things for you and
knowing what they want for you so when
i'm with my mom all my mom cares about
is my health
right my mom does not care how
successful i am how many videos happen
how many people i help even that and my
mom will get over there she's like how's
your health
are you taking care of yourself are you
sleeping well are you eating well like
that's my mom and it's like if i go and
i measure everything most of that that's
wrong but if i know that that's what my
mom wants for me that's beautiful that's
what i get from her and she'll take care
of that and same you know everyone plays
a different role in your life don't
expect everyone to play the role you
want and don't expect everyone to play
the same role recognize that everyone's
playing their role in your life and let
them play it that's what makes a good
movie if everyone played the same role
in a movie it'd be boring very boring
every day we recharge our phones but we
forget to recharge ourselves
let's just say we slept well the night
before which means we start our day with
a 100
charge
when we wake up in the morning we roll
over and 80 of us check our smartphones
before we brush our teeth we scroll
through social media we browse through
emails
that takes away 10 percent of our energy
let's say we now have 90 percent charge
left we then commute to work we spend
our day in the office in meetings
interacting with colleagues finishing
off projects and assignments
we now have 40
charge left
on the way home we commute through
traffic
or on the train and that takes away
another let's say 10
we now have 30
charge left
we come home and switch on netflix talk
to someone about what our day was like
and sometimes we lose another 10 percent
we now have 20
charge left at 20 on our phones usually
the charge bar goes red we get an alert
we get a message that tells us that we
only have twenty percent battery left
the question is do we notice when our
charge is at twenty percent or ten
percent there are always signs from our
bodies our brains our minds but are we
tuned in one of the best things we can
do to recharge is to exercise the
hardest part of any workout is actually
the 15 minutes leading up to it we come
up with 15 reasons why we don't want to
sweat and we change our mind 15
different times cnn reports that when
you work out your brain creates more
serotonin which sends messages to your
nervous system of happiness and
well-being working out for 30 to 40
minutes every day can recharge our
battery by 20
meditation is an incredible way to
recharge our batteries exactly what the
gym does for the body meditation can do
for the mind
meditation gives us down time physically
mentally emotionally and spiritually
meditation also directly impacts your
entire nervous system by reducing your
body's productions of stress-related
chemicals such as cortisol
meditation is a great way to recharge
and can take you back up 20
we've all heard about incredible morning
routines but the one thing that can make
a huge difference to your recharge is
your evening routine 35 of us are not
getting the recommended seven hours of
sleep per night remember every body and
mind is different make sure you find the
amount of time you need to get that
serious battery recharge and the 75-year
study by harvard found that beyond
anything
the real sense check for happiness and
meaning in life
was relationships connections
interactions with depth that are
fulfilling and full of joy making time
for deep meaningful interactions every
day can give the recharge our battery
seriously needs
what if we've recharged ourselves
as much as we recharge our phones
because if we don't we'll end up like
one of our phones
in the bottom of some drawer in our home
here's the shocking truth about
loneliness
this is why we need to take it more
seriously surveys show one out of three
adults are lonely and the health impacts
of loneliness are shocking studies have
shown that people who are lonely are 50
percent more likely to die before their
time
researchers show that loneliness is as
damaging to our health as not smoking
one not two but 15 cigarettes per day
only around half of americans say they
have meaningful face-to-face
interactions with a loved one family or
friend every single day members of
generation z say they are the loneliest
generation and experience more health
problems as a result of it loneliness
was also linked with less physical
activity compulsive use of digital
technology and not being able to share
our problems with others in a study of
20 000 adults 54
say that they don't know one person that
knows them well additionally 56 of
people said that the people they
surround themselves with are not
necessarily with them and approximately
40 percent said that they lack
companionship don't have meaningful
relationships and feel isolated all of
us have been in a crowd but felt lonely
all of us have been invited to a party
but wanted to leave
all of us have likes on social media but
don't feel loved in real life
so many of us can get comments on our
posts but can't get a friend to call us
back
loneliness is real
so here's what we have to do
after studying over 2500 consumers over
six years research found that people
that see material possessions as a sign
of success
felt more lonely investing our money in
experience rather than things is a great
way of breaking the loneliness and
materialism cycle schedule a time each
day to talk to a friend
take a class to learn something new
volunteer to deepen your sense of
purpose spend time with people who look
more like your future than your past
the mental health charity mind recites
two factors that can cause loneliness
someone either not having enough social
contact
or more interestingly being surrounded
by people but not feeling understood
loved or cared for
notice it's not just being around people
but being understood it's not just being
invited and present but feeling like
you're contributing loneliness really
comes then from a lack of significance
or lack of worth and what you bring to
the table and what value you truly offer
lonely is not being alone it's the
feeling that no one loves you
so start by loving yourself i read an
incredible study that changed the way i
create and think
and it said that the human mind can't be
logical and creative at the same time
how many of you have ever walked from a
highly creative brainstorm where you
were fueled with passion and then had to
talk about numbers and business and
right it's tough right anyone ever found
that quite difficult it's quite
challenging and the mind's like trying
to run from one side of the brain to the
other side of the brain so what i do is
i create in depth so i go really deep
into my creation and then i go really
deep into everything else that i have to
do so before i went to india i created
my content in advance
and so when i was in india i was able to
really switch off
so the beauty of being able to be in
india for 21 or 30 days or wherever i am
in the world for that matter and then
not having to think of creativity as
stress or pressure i'm able to do
creativity as a form of passion and
service and so when i was in india i was
able to not look at instagram i was able
to not look at facebook i was able to
completely switch off for 21 days when i
was there earlier in january and i
started my year in the way i wanted to
so i was meditating for eight hours a
day of spending time with my teachers
who are mind-blowing and incredible and
trying to learn from them and taking
knowledge and wisdom from them and
continuously praying to be of more
service this year and make a difference
this year so that's how i chose to spend
my january and i had so many people
saying to me they were just like jay
it's january things are going well in
your career how can you take 21 days off
right that pressure that noise of like
things are going good for you how can
you take time off i was like things are
going good because i'm doing this
all right like you know i had one of my
teachers that has kept saying to me for
years he goes if you want to move three
steps forward you have to go three steps
deep
and so if i'm not going forward i know
it's because i haven't gone deep
so for me
that's a big priority for me and that's
what i try and do when i'm i try and do
that every day but i also believe in
immersive experiences
so a lot of us today we live in this
world which is like 10 minutes a day do
it for 10 minutes today everything will
be great and that is great there's
nothing wrong with that
but imagine you spent
with a boy or a girl your partner
whoever it was someone that you just
started dating imagine you spent 10
minutes a day with them
how long would it take you to figure out
whether you wanted to fall in love with
them or not
probably a long time
and so when you go immersive if you
spend a weekend away with someone you
know whether you like them or not and
meditation mindfulness all these habits
are the same the more you immerse
yourself
the more you get an experience that
stays with you the more that you can
live with that experience and keep going
back to it for 10 minutes a day
so i really believe in immersive
experiences i love the 10 minute a day
advice but i also deeply believe in
having an deep immersive
absorbed experience
that completely takes over your whole
body mind and soul in 2016 i moved out
to new york so just let me paint a
picture of 2016.
i moved three jobs
i got married wow i moved country
and i
just just started a whole new life like
my life just transformed so we went to
all of that with my wife in one year and
by the way all of that was surprises the
job chains were surprises yeah the
country change was a surprise the
marriage was not a surprise we planned
apart from everything else everything
was a surprise now i said i like
surprises so i can roll with it but my
point is that's a lot of transition so
much transition and i felt the burden of
being in a new city where we had no
family we had no friends
and my wife who loves being around her
family and no one understands just how
close she is to them i felt this burden
on me
that i had taken away her time with her
family and now she was alone so i was
going out to work and she'd be crying at
home
and i was thinking she's got no friends
she's got no support and i know you can
relate to this with moving and
relationships and so much going on and
so it's like i'm dealing with that and
guess what six months later
i have to leave and move on and
work on a new career to build everything
myself and then i'm four months away
from being broke
and so on top of all of this i've now
got four months away from being broke
i've got enough money money saved for
four months to pay for rent and
groceries and that's in new york city
and that's it and guess what even on top
of that i've got 30 days before my visa
runs out and i'm kicked out of the
country so i can't even live here
anymore
so not only have i just got married
moved job three times changed career
again had to move into apartment four
months of being broke and i might get
kicked out in 30 days and my renewal for
my visa cost fifteen thousand dollars
so that's gonna eat into those four
months
i have probably never been
under that much emotional
physical and and mental pressure in my
life like genuinely i felt it and i
thought my body changed my my breath was
more stressed i would be breathing
faster shorter breaths not deep breaths
heartbeating faster not working out you
get into lazy habits you start craving
junk food you have energy i'm living in
a 500 square foot apartment with my wife
which is which is tiny like everything's
in that space and guess what we both
work from home so i'm now sitting at a
desk hunched over trying to figure stuff
out she's trying to cook in the same
room like i'm trying to just just trying
to figure out what to do and i remember
the next morning
sending like a hundred emails to people
and just being like this is who i am
this is what i can do how can we serve
and that was the same year that i ended
up meeting you later in that year
and the beginning three months of that
journey was so stressful like they were
so stressful because i was like what if
i have to move back to london
what am i gonna say to her parents i
mean i just took their daughter away
like uh
just got married i've lived in new york
city for six months and my life's
falling apart like you know so much and
i've got all these views but there's
nothing there's nothing happening here
we met also you also i mean at this time
you're also
growing so much how are you able to
create and
reach this impact with your videos as
that's growing
while you're under so much stress and
uncertainty and i stopped a bit at that
time like things slowed down
like things slowed down i remember i
wasn't creating as much as i was because
i don't enjoy creating from stress or
pressure and i don't think you can
really create something from stress and
pressure so we really slowed down at
that time and when i was creating i was
creating from a place of recognizing
that i could share what i had learned
and what i had grown in so far so
anything i was sharing was like this is
what i've learned so far so that was the
biggest pain that i've been through in
the last seven years for sure
and all i can say is that i remember
coming home to my wife knowing that this
was going to be the truth and i came and
i said to i said to her i guarantee you
this is going to be the best thing that
ever happened to us what the pain the
pain i said that till the night i came
home and then she gave up literally came
up i looked in the eyes and got this is
the scenario
and i just want you to know that i
guarantee to you this is the best thing
that's ever going to happen to us and i
said to them this is this is a monk
statement that we used to repeat i said
to her i'm just not going to judge the
moment
don't judge the moment because what we
do is we try to label moments as good or
bad
and when you label the moment as bad it
now does not have the opportunity to
become good i'll give an example if i go
i don't like this book this book's bad
right and i don't and i love this book
but if i say that guess what i will
never pick it up and recognize the value
that's inside of it because you've
labeled it yes and we label stuff like
we label oh that restaurant's bad
but when you label them emotions
that person's bad now you can't learn
from that person oh great one that's a
really good one
as soon as you start labeling people or
anything is good or bad you limit it you
stop it from being something else and
here's the truth
every moment can evolve into being
anything if you give it the opportunity
to right but as soon as you say it's got
no value anymore you lose it
and so for me i had to say to myself
don't judge the moment and i'd keep
repeating that don't judge where you're
at don't judge what's happening yeah
don't judge it as negative don't don't
just start saying it's negative because
yes we've all been in positions
where a gift turned into a curse and a
curse turned into a gift it's true right
we've always our dreams came true and it
ended up not being what we wanted
exactly it fell apart and it led us into
our dream tony why is it that so many
people that win the lottery yeah go
broke yeah gifts can turn into curses
too but because we label them as the
best moment in our life or the worst
moment in our life whereas when you
approach things to neutrality and just
what you have on the table you can be
like okay what am i going to do next
i'll have you related to deep
spiritual learnings
and at the same time being happy
and content in the material world
without going
crazy
interesting question
[Music]
i think that's this point of spiritual
training
so it's like when we're when we're
immature in our spiritual learning we're
just starting out
when you first learn the first everyone
remember the first time they learned
something and they were like i'm never
talking to my family ever again right
it's like
because because you learn a little bit
and you go
oh my god i've been doing it all wrong
and now i can't talk to that person i
can't ever go to that event again and
you start making all these big decisions
based on something small that you've
learned
and so i think in the beginning of our
lives because to protect ourselves which
is a very normal desire and very good
and very human we think okay i need to
take care of this so now i'm going to
shut out from all of this but as we grow
we realize we can give more back
and so one of the ways i've always
thought about it is
if you look at the ocean and you see
someone drowning
you want to help them
but if you go in too soon and you're not
strong enough it's likely that you're
going to get pulled in
and at that point it's easier to shout
out to a lifeguard who can come along
who's trained who's disciplined who's
committed who can go and make a
difference
and so for me in my life i'm always
looking at if i can't bring someone up
i'm not going to spend time with them if
they're going to pull me down
and it's drawing that line for me
so if i've been ever scared about my
spiritual rather than putting them down
and going oh i'm not spending time with
them because i'm putting them down if i
can't lift them up then i'm going to
protect myself by not being dragged down
but if i can pull them up if i can lift
them up
then that's when i'm able to go into
that space and make an impact to make a
difference and that line has really
helped me
not go crazy because now i'm not doing
it based on a judgment of them i'm
reflecting on my own abilities and flaws
and and the difference i can make and
i'm taking a taking a stance it's like
someone asked me the other day what is a
complaint when we're talking about
litter
a complaint is you see a piece of trash
on the floor and you go oh la's so dirty
you've removed the agency that you can
have an impact on that
a statement is oh la's a bit dirty
there's trash and flow i'm going to pick
that up and
throw it away
right taking that responsibility so when
we're irresponsible in our spiritual
lives we judge everyone and judge
everything
and we mature we start looking at
through compassion empathy and
connection and recognize we were just
there a few years ago
and that's the biggest anchor in my life
is recognizing that
i was addicted to and still am in
different ways
things that i don't believe are good for
me spiritually and i was that i was that
guy i was that kid you know and it's
taken a journey and someone had to
believe in me someone had to invest in
me someone had to reach their hand
without being forced in and pull me out
and so that allows me to continue to
operate in the world i hope that answers
your question if you want another
amazing jay shetty video check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there so i talk about how we fear
the wrong things
what do we fear so most of us are
fearful of how our friends are reacting
what's happening on social media and
what's the random bit of news that we
heard